Are we all here?
Why are you sitting in this chair?
What do you want out of life?
What do you think it is?
I know you see the answer,
but why are you here,
okay.
If you follow the trail of wise,
it's always happiness.
This is something you should all do.
Like sit down and be like,
why do I want this?
Why do I want the girlfriend?
Why do I want the money?
Why do I want success?
Why do I want to hustle?
Why do I want to have a purpose?
Why do I want friends?
It's always to be happy.
I want the fucking beautiful girlfriend so all my friends can see me with the
beautiful girlfriend and uh,
they'll finally approve of me in this means I can finally approve of myself.
You know,
if you go inside your body and you're like,
well,
how do I feel?
And not just from your subjective perspective,
let's just say someone else other than you is transported in your body.
Would they have an enjoyable experience right now where they feel good?
Would it be a pleasant experience?
Probably not.
Like it can guarantee you're not all 10 out of 10 back in the day I was probably
a good three out of 10,
24,
seven like that was my default.
Three out of 10 all the time.
Uh,
just always anxious,
introverted.
Okay,
this is why we're all here.
Okay?
Now by happiness,
and this is important to understand.
I'm not talking about the emotion of feeling happy because if you think about
feeling happy,
what does it really,
it's this temporary escape for relief from pain.
That's it.
You know,
um,
will be somehow bought into the fact that we think our default is unhappiness
here.
What do we assume?
I'm unhappy unless,
and then we try to find ways to feel happy and it's usually this escape from our
default that is unhappiness or so we think and we call that happiness every time
we succeed.
In escaping we call the hobbies most common answer.
Like what makes you happy?
Going to a movie,
watching a cool TV show,
uh,
eating food,
um,
sex,
masturbation,
drugs,
drinks,
smoking.
It's an escape.
You know,
like that's when I'm happy,
but it's not true happiness.
Why?
Because it's temporary and you don't fix the cause.
The underlying problem is still there.
The fact that you assumed that unhappiness as your default.
Okay.
And these are some obvious ones like smoking,
drugs on and so forth.
But it could also be simple things like drinking Kombucha or drinking a green
juice.
I feel happy when I drink this really healthy juice.
That's cool.
But what happens when it ends?
When happiness depends on something,
it's always temporary.
It's literally like we're putting our fucking hand like in the flames,
like in the fire who were like,
let's put a little water.
I'm happy until you're back in the fucking flames.
It's crazy.
It's,
that's what we call happiness.
And as I really happiness,
he's getting,
you know,
deep down inside that the underlying problem still there and you know,
it's temporary.
So it's that worry.
How long is it going to last?
The fact you need to do something to be happy is reinforcing the assumption that
you're not enough to be happy right now.
You don't deserve it.
It's not your default.
And as long as it's not your defaults,
you are fucked.
No matter what you do,
You can get a bigger purpose.
You can get more things.
You can get more girls who can get more validation.
You are fucked.
So it's getting back to that assumption.
Getting back to that false assumption that's wrong.
Where your default is unhappiness.
Why not assume the opposite?
Who says your default is unhappiness?
Why isn't your default happiness?
Okay?
And uh,
this year,
funny enough is why we're seeking this state.
It's because it is our default because they're fucking basic nature.
We're all born,
whole,
born happy.
And somewhere along the way we assume the opposite.
And we live our lives based on this false assumption.
And until we reexamine it,
until we step out of this paradigm,
we are fucked.
We know that we're not going to find happiness based on all of those things.
Like right now,
if I gave you literally everything in the world,
like let's say you had everything of the world,
you are the god of the world,
would you be happy
if the answer is no,
why do you keep fucking seeking hit and all these things and all these
validation and all these people and all these objects and all these green juices
and drinks and all this knowledge and all these relationships.
If you literally had everything in the world,
you'd sell it.
I'd be happy.
It's pretty crazy because again,
it's still within that paradigm.
What you're seeking is in another paradigm,
a good quote to kind of a hammer.
This home is we're trying to seek the infinite with the finite.
We're in this world of like limited things and we're seeking the unlimited.
It doesn't matter how much limited things you get,
you're never going to get the unlimited,
you know,
and until we find this too,
as I said,
everything will be compulsive.
You can't find something out there that is in here.
It's like if you're trying to seek what you already have,
you're never going to fucking find it.
You know,
it's like our default is happy.
We tell ourselves we're not happy and we tried to seek it out there.
And,
uh,
this year doesn't affect the fact that you can go out and get all these cool
things.
Like it doesn't affect,
for example,
passion,
purpose,
success,
et cetera.
Like that whole list I said before,
being grateful,
being giving,
uh,
you know,
being successful,
making money,
getting girls,
getting in relationship,
having your fucking grandkids,
totally fine to go do that,
but it shouldn't be coming from that compulsive place.
It's not about the thing,
it's about the place it's coming from or you doing it to see completion.
Are you doing it to be happy?
Are you doing it to fill that void or you it to escape yourself?
Or are you doing it coming from a place of abundance where it's no longer
compulsive?
That's the key.
It's not the thing.
It's the place it's coming from.
You can be as successful as you want,
but it's not compulsive and it's different motives behind it.